empathy at its foundation includes
curiosity
um one of the examples i like to share
of what empathy looks like in the
workplace
is here's a fairly normal scenario uh
a manager walks into somebody's office
and says hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before if
you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter i don't know what's going
to happen
an organization that embodies empathy
that same circumstance sounds different
it says
somebody walks into the office and says
hey your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay
what's going on i'm worried about you
there's the assumption that the person
is not the problem but they have a
problem
and if we can if they can if we can give
them a safe space for them to tell us
what they're going through
personally or professionally then we can
help them
um at least we can at least we can be
there for them to support them
um and so and so you know empathy is
core
to what good leadership looks like it's
seeing people as
people and recognizing that we all have
personal issues and struggles and
insecurities and egos and ambitions and
all of we're just
messy balls of human beings and and you
know and
and fundamentally leadership is not
about the results
leadership is about taking care of the
people who are responsible for the
results
it's it's a human job that's what
leadership is